Looking for the cause of continued stomach bloating and increased cramping an x-ray yesterday showed multiple pelvic leolets
and
calcification projected over the right kidney
measuring seven
millimeters
so a flea bullet
and calcification over the right kid is flea bullets are calcification in
tenderness issue that's I wouldn't be causing stomach bloating these are these are just something you
see on x-rays so that would not be causing
stomach bloating. Ultrasound showed presumed calcified lymph endopathy of the lymph of the left neck
that isn't uncommon either so when a person has increased lymph nodes for
reasons of infection those they can become calcified. Typically that does not cause a problem
if you read this I read these questions yet so I also still have painful para
rotted gland which is presumed to be clogged by a stone are these all calcium deposits presumably
stemming from the systemic imbalance what causes this and what could be done in what this
so there is a phenomena on in radiology when you see multiple flea bullets
flea bullets are calcifications in the pelvic area and you see calcification of lymph nodes you see
multiple calcifications and you can see calcifications at tenderness tendon insertion sites
there's a phenomena that we used to call used to use a word phrase that we used to use in radiology
called people are bone fours so it's not a technical term but it was a common old radiology term
there's people that lay down a lot of calcium now there have been theories on why there are people that
lay down a lot of calcium part of it has to do with issues with the parathyroid gland now your
parathyroid gland releases parathyroid hormone which one of the things that that does is it gets rid
of excess calcium in the blood through excretion in the kidneys so typically issues with the
parathyroid gland are diagnosed by looking at blood calcium levels so if a person has elevated
blood calcium levels so you do a regular cbc bleat metabolic panel and you'll see an elevated
blood calcium level the first thing that you think of is that the person has a parathyroid tumor
so parathyroid tumors are benign so they're not cancerous but they're actually quite common
and that can increase blood calcium and that can increase calcium lay down you don't want to have
increased blood calcium because you could have calcium laid out in the arteries which causes
acrylorosclerosis so but if a person has multiple flimless also they can have degenerative joint
disease and calcification of tendons as they attach muscles to the bones calcium calcification
of lymph nodes and things and they can have normal blood calcium so that it's not a parathyroid
problem per se but they just tend to lay down calcium it can be because they're taking you know they
have a history throughout their life of taking excess calcium through supplementation used to be
years and years ago that it was recommended that women especially post-metaposal women take
1500 milligrams of calcium on a daily basis well they don't make that recommendation anymore because
it's been proven that that causes an increase in acrylorosclerosis of an increase
biocardial infarctions the calcium that was typically given in calcium that is supplemented into
our food products like in you know enriched flour enriched cereals and things is a calcium
that's this is why i'm so keen on properly found minerals typically the calcium that's used in
enriched foods that you'd get is calcium carbonate calcium carbonate is limestone you're so
unlucky to absorb it it will easily cause laid out of calcium in the tissues and laid out of calcium
in the arteries so that could be an issue where a person was taking calcium especially if they're
taking the wrong form of calcium or they have issues with calcium excretion or they have issues with
just a calcium mineral balance in the blood so there's multiple
theories of the causes of people that are quote unquote bone formers
and there is a reason why that that's a radiology term because you'd see it
unplayed film x-rays so you'd see it on x-rays where a person has a lot of calcium
formation a lot of calcification of ligaments a lot of calcification of tendons
there they can be they can admit it with stones they can get their carbon to have kidney stones
so those that's would be common findings of somebody that we used to call as a that person is a
bone former or so that that there's multiple reasons for that so digging to the reasons would be
helpful and one of the ways that you could is by looking at past blood tests so specifically what
a person who has who is a bone former what should they shy away from well they should shy it might
be wise to shy away from oxalates it might that's oxalates in your food it might be wise to shy away
from calcium supplements so I mean that's why we privately learned the Clare Multimid
product because it doesn't have a lot of calcium in it so I think it has a couple hundred
milligrams of calcium and at the full dose so you and it's balanced with magnesium and the other minerals
don't want to be taking excess calcium unless you have you know metastasis to bone and you have
a lytic bone disorder meaning metastasis which is going to be lytic attacking the bone and and
drying calcium off the bone or you have osteoporosis and then you want to be taking the right form of calcium
and you want to be taking mk4 which is the type of vitamin K that you should be taking to help get
calcium into the bone itself mk4 not mk7